as mentioned this has been a very
difficult day for the fox news family
because two of our co-workers have died
in ukraine cameraman pierre zakszewski
and journalist and translator alexandra
kushinova
they were working with correspondent
benjamin hall outside keeve when
incoming fire hit their vehicle benjamin
was seriously wounded and is in the
hospital
pierre and sasha did not survive
pierre leaves behind his wife michelle
and a loving family
and a lot of colleagues who are
absolutely heartbroken at the loss of a
legend
we were just outside the refugee camp
filming filming refugees and we could
hear there was gunfire in the background
pierre zakrzewski or zach as many called
him has been with fox for years
in and out of war zones on the run the
gunmen are coming closer here let's go
grab the sticks before ukraine pierre
was on the ground in iraq
in afghanistan
in syria
he covered conflicts between countries
and helped us report from the middle of
riots
pierre was a steady presence in
uncertain times when a correspondent or
producer arrived and saw pierre waiting
for them they knew they were in good
hands
because he could do just about anything
he shot video fixed equipment produced
stories and edited pieces on the fly
pierre also seemed to always know the
background of every location every story
and he had an extraordinary ability to
do his work under incredible pressure
and without sleep some of our
correspondents who worked closely with
him feel this loss
especially hard today trey yanks posted
this photo with pierre said he was as
good as they come selfless brave
passionate jonathan hunt says he's never
forgotten the smile and welcome he
received from pierre in 2003 when he
first arrived in baghdad he says pierre
made everyone a better journalist and a
better person amy kellogg says pierre
was warm and generous with his time and
he was a rare breed of war reporter who
never got jaded greg palcott says he and
pierre were embedded with a marine
company during iraq's battle of fallujah
he says that pierre saved his life on
many occasions over the years he adds
that pierre hated sitting around the
newsroom he wanted to be out chasing the
story
and greg noted that even when the worst
was happening pierre would repeat his
favorite advice to keep on smiling
and that obviously is a lot tougher
today because we lost not only a
colleague but a mentor a leader and a
wonderful friend we offer our deepest
condolences to all who knew pierre and
all who loved him
pierre
zakszewski was just 55 years old we also
send our condolences to the family of
journalist alexandra
sasha as she's known was just 24 years
old she was serving as a consultant
helping our teams navigate the city
gathered news speak with sources our
correspondents and producers say she was
hard-working funny kind
and brave
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else